ready when you are vocal warm-ups Oh
habit from my stage walk okay look
Trevor this is our last day okay last
day yes finally and we've covered a lot
of the logistics your recruitment by
Aldrich Killian the creation of an
amalgam warlord by his think tank whom I
brought to life carry on the one
question that most people ask me when I
tell them that I know you is how could
he have not known what was going on
through the woods hmm lovely okay
that was the break that broke me well
right there
you seem to typify your life as a series
of missed opportunities but yet you
don't tend to take responsibility for
many of them my responsibility is to my
muse I'm an actor
loved not a bloody rocket surgeon hmm
but possibly your portrayal has angered
some people no I mean some some are very
dangerous but you don't have to tell me
May I've seen there's billions in it
message boards vicious I'm not talking
about the message wars I'm talking about
the ten rings come again the terrorist
group historically associated with
demand room officially they're dormant
but evidence suggests that they're
becoming more active well the ten rings
are they real it's R all documented are
you so cool
Trevor you told me that when you got
this role that you had researched it
thoroughly yeah but what an act or tells
you've done the research it means he's
switched on this computer googled his
own name another quick so you mean
to tell me
you don't know the history of the
Mandarin and himself he was a warrior
King inspired generations of men to the
Middle Ages perhaps even further back in
time not the Mandarin they'll remember
is the name Trevor Slattery it's a brand
tread you're right
and for that sin you will soon suffer
horribly with a hole in your body for
every ring of our faith I'm an
out-of-work actor love you've no idea
what I'm capable of and thanks to the
CBS network I'm pretty good with a
handgun Oh
consider this a lesson in what's real
and what's not
why do people keep pointing guns at my
head
please I don't want to I don't want
to target acquired an imposition
extraction unit mobilize I'm not the one
that's going to you mr. Slattery
I'm here to break you out that's at
least not really
you see there's somebody who wants to
meet you Donna him you know
you took his name and now he wants it
back
no sorry I still don't get it
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my video all about iron man
the real Mandarin of the MCU in the
shang-chi movie during Marvel phase four
and how they're changing things heading
into the next big Avengers movie
Avengers 5 we're doing that huge
Avengers infinity saga box set giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best theory
about who the real Mandarin is on the
video they have actually cast the actor
for the film I'll talk about him but we
do some backstory about who the real
Mandarin is in the way that the Marvel
Universe is used him so far in how
that's going to change with the Shang Chi
movie the clip at the beginning of this
is all hail the king the Marvel one-shot
that they release after Iron Man 3
because fans got so upset about what
they did with the Mandarin character
from the comics originally they didn't
plan on doing an actual Mandarin but
they saw how fans reacted to Iron Man 3
so they said don't oh wait wait wait
there's still a real Mandarin out there
we'll see him someday but think about
how long ago Iron Man 3 was it's been
that long since they found a place to
put the actual comic book Mandarin
character the full title of the
shang-chi movie is shang-chi in the
legend of the ten rings as in the ten
rings organization but also the literal
ten rings the alien rings that you put
on your fingers that the comic book
Mandarin wears there's sort of a smaller
version of what you would consider the
Infinity Gauntlet in the Infinity stones
just ultra powerful weapons of mass
destruction when wielded by the wrong
person in this clip Jackson Norris
played by scoot mcnairy a member of the
ten rings infiltrates Seagate prison to
get close to Trevor Slattery the fake
Mandarin get a full confession about how
he faked his role as the Mandarin for
aldrich killian in aim and out himself
as a total idiot publicly before the ten
rings breaks him out of prison to face
the real mandarins justice for sowing
his good evil name to the world and
turning him into a joke because as they
say during the clip the real Mandarin up
to this point right now had fallen into
legend as Jackson Norris says the real
ten rings had just been dormant most of
what you know about the ten rings you
only learned through the Iron Man films
but the way the Marvel movies explain it
is that they're actually a core group
started by the original Mandarin they
would go on to create splinter cells all
over the world
primarily the Middle East with no real
communication between each cell so the
leader of this faction of the ten rings
who was working with Obadiah Stane to
purchase stark tech weapons had no real
knowledge or communication with the true
Mandarin any more than aldrich killian
did but as jackson says while he's
narrating here the legends of the
mandarin go back thousands of years and
say that he became this feared warlord
right now if you think about it the only
group of people on the planet that we
know about that are capable of living
thousands of years are the Eternals
aside from the Asgardians
or aliens that visit from outer space in
the comics though the real mandarins
life is prolonged by the ten rings of
power it's a very Lord of the Rings
Gollum situation his preciouses keep him
going for years and years to that end at
least in the comics there's only one
Mandarin he doesn't have any descendants
that take up the mantle like a normal
dynasty this is where I think the Marvel
movies are going to change things so when
Jackson is telling the legends of the
Mandarin from ancient Chinese history I
think it's implied that he's just
talking about the first Mandarin the one
who found the 10 alien rings of power
and used them to style himself the
Mandarin then went on to create the ten
rings organization and ruled over
ancient China from the shadows in all
the various tales of the Mandarin from
later years the Jackson talks about are
actually speaking about his descendants
each of whom were probably groomed to
take the mantle and wield the literal
ten rings that's how you explained that
the Mandarin wasn't around in any of the
other big Avengers movies and didn't get
directly involved as far as we know it
but the way Marvel does things is that
it lays seeds buried deep in earlier
movies like the ten rings organization
showed up during the first ant-man movie
trying to be one of the groups buying
the Yellow Jacket technology so that
means that the Mandarin wanted his hands
on yellowjacket technology but also this
person was meant to be a member of Hydra
so that means that the mandarins 10 ring
organization has infiltrated Hydra while
Hydra itself had infiltrated shield and
now because of the events of Iron Man 3
Jackson's implying that's no longer the
case in the current Mandarin is coming
back with a vengeance in one of the
first things he's going to do is make
sure the world fears in respects his
name again after Trevor Slattery just
drug it through the mud in Iron Man 3 I
know you're asking if Ben Kingsley's
character is going to have a cameo during
Shang chi the
groomer right now in the early theory on
Schanke and how it connects to Avengers
endgame an Iron Man is that based on
what Marvel has told us around comic-con
Schanke is a hero he's going to join a
future Avengers roster when it
eventually forms in Avengers 5 in the
movie itself we'll work a lot like the
way they did the Black Panther movie
just in terms of how much crossover you
saw with all the other Marvel characters
and movies they referenced a whole lot
of characters from Captain America Civil
War the plot of Black Panther picks up
right after Captain America Civil War
happens in a couple really big
characters return like Ulysses Klaw
in Winter Soldier but for the most part
it was a huge global threat that they
had to stop without a ton of other big
a-list Avengers running around in it and
it was a relatively self-contained movie
- Wakanda this secret area that you'd
never seen before same idea with the ten
rings in the real Mandarin shang-chi if
he's been living in isolation for years
in the shadows it makes sense that he'd
have some super-secret territory that no
one was allowed to enter just like
Wakanda in the Pin Pacific Asian region
of the world they're filming the movie
on Australia right now so that'll give
you an idea for what the terrain will
look like during the movie but on a
basic level shang chi explainer he's
supposed to be the best martial artists
in the world his title in the comics is
literally shang-chi master of kung fu
so there was any question about what
kind of fighting style they'll use in
the movie and the actor who's playing
the Mandarin is also the same person who
starred as it man during the Grand
Master that just means they're going to
have one badass kung-fu fight between
shang-chi in the Mandarin before the
movies over but here's the big change
that the movie is making - Shang chi's
backstory from the comics so in the
comics shang Chi's father is fu Manchu
very notable comic book villain who lies
to Schanke about his crimes trains him
to become the world's greatest weapon
then uses him to take down his enemies
one at a time all the while misleading
him about what they're really doing
until Shang chi figures out his
father's terrible and turns against him
so they're not going to do fu Manchu
during the Shang Chi movie they're just
doing the Mandarin so the Mandarin is
gong to be one of the biggest villains on
earth post Avengers endgame it sounds
like they're really going to go for a Star Wars
Darth Vader thing where Shang Chi
grows up without knowing who his father
really is until one day he discovers
he's the real Mandarin and has to turn
against him I really hope they wind up
paying that off so that they can
the spider-man civil war joke when they
meet for the first time in the next
Avengers movie and he tells him the
Empire Strikes Back reference the
connection to Iron Man in the Avengers
movies is mostly through Iron Man 3 in
the events of Avengers endgame the movie
will have to have some contextual
flashbacks to events set in the past in
order to explain Shang chi origin in
the origin of the Mandarin in the origin
of the 10 alien rings but most of the
present day of the movie will be set
after the events of Avengers and game
after everyone has been snapped back by
the Hulk in THE Mandarin is probably
going to try and use the chaos to try and
seize more power they haven't completely
confirmed the other brand-new Marvel
comic book characters that are going to
debut during the movie or which Avengers
characters might cross over but let me
know in the comments which big Marvel
characters do you want to see show up
during the Shang Chi movie if it's going to
be a relatively self-contained like
black panther was it would be really
cool if they had a post-credits scene
like the first Iron Man film where real
Nick Fury not scroll Nick Fury shows up
to recruit shang-chi into the next
Avengers team before Avengers 5 so
comment if there's any big Marvel video
you want me to make or big question that
you have but every one click here to
learn about Loki crossing over with
Doctor Strange 2 and Scarlet Witch and
click here for my brand new
Rick and Morty season 4 trailer thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight!